From birth, we have learned to get what we want by lying, making people feel guilty,...
...asking again and again and thus wearing the other person down, and so on.
Yet, the best way to get something from people is to tell them exactly why.
To start with, you have to find reasons why your request is in the other person's best interest.
If it isn't, then you shouldn't really ask.
Being honest will make you feel happier getting what you want.
It also works better in the long term, because people respect honesty and will learn to trust you.
Your words will have more value and people will listen to you.
There is no need to be persuasive, charming or clever to be effective.
The important thing is that you should practice in your head.
Imagine something you want to gain,...
...and think of reasons why it would be in the other person's best interest.
And imagine telling them.
Make it a habit and you will always benefit from it.